[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
speaking of fox sports
first things first on fox sports every
morning monday through friday
and one of the great co-hosts there nick
wright joining us on the program
uh nick thanks for joining us here i was
watching this morning you did have some
thoughts on kawhi leonard and the
clippers and
and how this all plays out what would
you do
with with uh this situation if you were
running the clippers
well if i were running the clippers i i
i
asked myself why am i running the
clippers like why is that my lot in life
but then once i get over that
i i'd recognize that kawhi's got us in a
rough spot
in that he has three options right he
could have opted in
and then signed a four-year extension
that's the most guaranteed money
available to him he didn't do that
he could opt out and then sign a
four-year contract but that would be
illogical you would have just done the
first option
so it looks like he's going to opt out
if he's going to stay
he's going to sign a one plus one so
he'll
you know get paid 40 million this year
to probably not play
and then be a free agent again next year
and i don't know dan people the the
argument that is well then he can sign a
five year after this coming year 235
million dollar deal
i don't know that i'm interested in
signing kawhi leonard for his age
32 through 36 season
when his body is broken down more
than it should have already also you
know i
i was one of the few people two years
ago who told you the clippers wouldn't
make it and this year
told you the nets wouldn't make it i
don't know if the nets are going to be
much better next year
next year all the nets guys are free
agents
if if let's say kwai signs the one plus
one dan
and he's a free agent and he's like okay
now i'll take my four or five year max
and james harden is also a free agent
it's like this ain't as fun as i thought
it would be
i'm from la i'd like to go back
if you're the clippers can you make an
argument you'd rather have paul george
with james harden than paul george with
kawhi i think you could
he's a free agent kyrie katie your free
agent jimmy butler is a free agent
bradley beals a free agent
next year's free agency is very wide
open if i'm the clippers i mean i find
out he's having surgery because skip
bayless reports it
that's not great that's not how you want
to find out the news
so i don't know the whole thing's
frustrating about the clippers yeah i
don't think given that injury that he's
going to play
and given that kawhi's time frame for
coming back from an injury
he's going to be far more cautious than
somebody else might be
but this might be a situation do you
sign him like the nets signed
kevin durant he's coming off the
achilles and they still signed him
knowing that he wasn't going to play
that first year
yeah but katie didn't sign a one plus
one yeah like i don't
i think they would have signed him to
if he picked up the option a four-year
extension but
that's not what he opted for i i think
if
i think they would sign him right now to
a four-year deal
but that would be totally illogical from
his perspective if he wanted that he
would have picked up the option
and then got four additional years so
essentially a five-year deal
so i i don't think that is available to
them
i think he's gonna say i'm gonna sign a
one plus one
once again be able to hold your feet to
the fire and this year i'm probably not
going to play like
would the nets have signed kd to a one
plus one coming off the achilles i don't
think so they signed it
saying he signed a three plus one which
is very different
it just feels like the clippers are
going to regret this one way or another
in two years
it's either kawhi is mvp like
or kawhi is injured again let me ask
let me start interrupt but just for the
next
two years if you could and they can't
make this trade but just
uh you know humor me here because both
these guys opted out of their deal
for the next two years would you rather
have chris paul or kawhi leonard if
you're the clippers
the same exact roster chris paul
yeah me too because a he's gonna play
this first year and b
i actually think it fits it's like oh
paul george can be our primary scorer
do what he did in the bubble like and
that is a wild thing to say but i think
that's where we're at
what about with the lakers are you okay
with russell westbrook
okay so i'm okay with it
and listen i i guess what i don't know
if you i don't
listen i was out of town last week uh so
i didn't you know
i wasn't on tv but i don't know if
you've heard russell westbrook struggles
from three-point range
it's an undercover story um
but i also think that this this trade
was
really covered poorly by the media so
all right mantras harold
was part of it he was leaving kyle kuzma
was part of it
i would have packed kuzma's bags for him
kcp was part of it kcp is a useful
player
but not a great player now the argument
is yeah but you could have used those
pieces to get buddy healed
i love buddy healed as much as anyone
that's not from either the bahamas or
the state of oklahoma
however as we see time and time again
dan
there's a lot of guys one of which is
hosting this show
that can shoot 40 some percent from
three with no pressure
but you ain't seen him in the nba
playoffs and come the nba playoffs it
might be a little different animal
so buddy healed was not a sure thing
like joe harris seems like an amazing
piece for the lakers yeah but he can't
shoot in the playoffs right so buddy
yields never played in a big nba game so
it's a little concerning
and so i understand the fit question
with russ
and i understand russ has never won but
kevin love never won chris bosh number
one anything davis number one kyrie
irving never won and then lebron put his
arms around him and they won
lakers will be great in transition there
will be a
far lighter workload on lebron in the
regular season because russ can win
games for you
and i think that the overall just
tenacity of what russ brings is a net
positive
but dan you do know what's going to
happen here because this is the exact
thing that happened when the lakers
traded for a.d
the lakers traded for a.d and here was
the commentary on every network
oh my god they gave up so much who's
going to defend
lebron's in year 17 a.d is you know
is he as good as we say he is then they
win the title and this is what i hear oh
super team i mean that's a super team of
course they win oh what are you going to
do
so all week is that there's no spacing
it's caveman basketball
what are you thinking russ is a trucker
have you seen the second spectrum
numbers
and then if they win the title it's
going to be oh my god lebron james how
much help does he need
i mean carmelo anthony how much help
does the guy need
let's go from the same people
that's what's going to happen well it is
lebron
so you know however somebody can twist
it to their benefit that they certainly
will
i i understand getting russ and i love
watching him
i don't think he he translates into wins
i think he translates into entertainment
i think he has stats
i know they got together and they
decided that they were going to
sacrifice part of their game to make it
all work together
i mean it sounds nice but russ still
can't shoot
that's true now if what so what's his
role
they're just going to say like teams did
to lonzo ball
go ahead shoot go ahead shoot and and
they'll just
you know they're not going to let him
drive so yeah but didn't the lakers win
the title with the
with teams doing that to rajon rondo
like that happened right
it's not like people were like oh my god
like rondo was gonna kill the spacing
people aren't that worried about
caruso's three-point shot and by the way
the bucks who over the last few years
have been a good three-point shooting
team
i felt like every playoff game it's like
wow that's the fewest three-pointers
they've shot
they've made in four years and they just
won the title
and by the way i think this is everyone
says the lakers are you know trying to
match what the nets
do they're the lakers the whole league
needs to be worried about keeping up
with milwaukee
and i do think that russ is just such a
pain in the ass
that pardon me that i do think if you
are playing either
milwaukee or brooklyn in the finals drew
or
kyrie is going to have to work like the
other team's point guard is going to
have to work
i do yeah spacing will be a problem i
think mello will help that
i think they're going to get mellow and
he shot 40 from three the last couple
years
and he made big shots and they'll get
some you know maybe they get wayne
ellington they'll find
some shooting i think i hope he's nick
wright first things first co-host
fox sports one we keep looking at these
scenarios in free agency
and you know kyle lowry is an object of
desire and
malcolm brogdon mike conley is going to
resign with you to like is there a
player that you go
boy if that happens or he leaves
is there a domino effect where you go
boy that that changes
the uh the hierarchy of power well aside
from kawhi right yeah and i guess kawhi
it's you know it's more of a
delayed i think lowry could have but
i i think miami with lowry they're still
like they're hard capped not literally
hard caps but they just have a ceiling
on what they can be i don't i don't
think they're a true championship
contender
i i'm really interested in what dallas
does
i think that luca he was my pick to an
mvp before this year started he came in
to you know camp out of shape and
never didn't get going early and then
came on late
i think lucas is about to win a gold
medal
and light the olympics on fire
and go into next year as you know
there's a pretty clear top four players
in basketball to me giannis lebron katie
and luca
but dallas all right like their big move
is it going to be
keep tim hartaway jr like so i think the
biggest moves aren't so much a free
agency
it's more trades meaning it's ben
simmons going to be traded
and is kristaps porzingis going to be
traded and
what does that look like because i think
the mavs
need more but if they get the right
pieces they could win the title lucas
that good
yeah i i said that in the first hour i
view dallas as sort of that sneaky team
that you know we we keep looking at the
shiny objects over here and and
you know that piecing some things
together i'm not sold on porzingis
uh with them can you could you trade
porzingis for ben simmons
so that's a really interesting one i
don't think philly does it
i think philly wants more i think that
would be debt for dallas
it helps your defense immediately ben
simmons
you know the can basically play the
position he needs to play which is like
the
five on offense and i think it makes a
lot of sense for dallas i don't think it
makes enough sense for philly
i think philly listen there's a reason
that all these
reported trades daryl was asking for
like four first-round picks and swaps
it daryl wants damien lillard and if the
blazers won't trade him damien lillard
for ben simmons then he wants to acquire
the pieces necessary to then trade for
damian lillard like you don't want my
player okay what if you want the pieces
i get for my player
with bradley beal is like a consolation
i do not think ben simmons is getting
traded
by daryl for 70 cents on the dollar i
think he's gonna go i think he's
comfortable going into the season with
him
and waiting and sing good to talk to you
good to have you back
and uh thanks for joining us nick
absolutely as always great to see you
guys talk to you soon
that's uh nick wright first things first
co-host on fox sports 1 monday through
friday